welcome everyone to this afternoon
session of the leveling of Housing and
Community select committee this
afternoon we're going to be looking at
funding for leveling up which is a
flagship priority policy for the
government to see
um how it's working in practice today
we're going to have
three panels the first has three elected
Mayors who will introduce themselves in
a minute then we go on to a panel with
the Welsh government and then one with
the Northern Ireland executive
um at the beginning I just asked members
of the community to put on record any
interest they may have that may be
relevant to the inquiry I'm the vice
president of the local government
Association moving around I'm a member
of Bedford Town billboard yeah I employ
a counselor in my office I also employ a
counselor in my office Bob I'm vice
president of the local government
Association and I employ counselors in
my office yeah employee council in my
office and I'm a member of the chill
Townsend board
I'm a vice president of the local
government Association I am a director
of uh eastleigh bid which is focusing on
leveling up in eastleigh Andrew vice
president of the LGA and I'm a board
member of Northampton forward right
um thank you for that and can we go over
to our Witnesses now we have
um first of all
um one of the uhmeds uh Tracy present
with us we'd like to introduce yourself
for Tracy hello it's uh great to be here
Tracy Brave in mayor of West Yorkshire
right and then we have two Mayors online
uh Andy Andy Street first of all yes
good afternoon everybody Andy Street
Mayor of the West Midlands and Andy
Burnham
hi everybody Andy Burnham mayor of
Greater Manchester since 2017. right
we'll come over to your questions in a
minute but just before we do that I
think on the street you'd like to see a
few words about the tragedy in solihull
uh to us at the beginning yes well Mr
chair you kindly invited me to do so so
uh it's obviously literally a tragedy
there is no other word for it genuine
accident which is a horrible remote
with ice but if there can be a good
thing in this situation it's that the
Emergency Services across fire police
and ambulance across the West Midlands
have conducted themselves with great
heroism over the last 24 hours so of
course our thoughts are with the
bereaved families and indeed the
community today who are in some Shock
yes sir thank you for that uh uh Andy
and I think uh the whole committee would
want to put on record
um you know our Our concern at this
awful loss and our thoughts are with the
family what must be the most awful time
for them uh and uh we uh really uh feel
for their loss on this tragic occasion
okay can we move on now to the uh issue
of the inquiry we're conducting
um
right so I'll begin with uh Tracy in the
room then I'll come to our two Mayors
online so first of all uh Tracy uh we
had a white paper uh you know well
publicized still well spoken about uh
um by by ministers who introduced it uh
on leveling up
um did the white paper and the
subsequent proposals in the uh in the
bill go further enough to support
Devolution as you would like to see it
in your area well thank you chair for
asking me to speak first but if I may
just also send condolences from the
people of West Yorkshire
um over to Andy's constituents it must
have been absolutely horrendous so the
leveling up white paper it was very
welcome it's absolutely necessary if we
are going to improve productivity and
our economy nationally that we level up
across the whole of the country it was a
well-written document
um it was good bedside reading and the
problem is is it needs to be attached to
finance and to money
we are collectively across the Mayors
were very positive that Michael Gove is
back in post he is a man that you can do
business with and wants to get things
done but we have all said and I really
do strongly believe that it can't just
be a one-man operation it has to be
across the whole of governments it has
to be across education and transport you
can't level up for example if you can't
connect people to jobs and college and
opportunities so there is a job of work
to be done with what we've got so far
there are challenges so the Brownfield
fund whilst welcome is challenging
because of our land values we
um we're powering through where we're
doing our best however the for example
in Bradford where land values are low
it's hard to make that sort of economic
argument so we've gone back to housing
and said is there a possibility we can
cluster sites so we can get that a
better that BCR make it work
unfortunately that's not happened so
that is a real challenge for us and
whilst we were also very grateful for
the extra 22 million that was given to
us a year in and we have to deliver in a
year less uh time frame than the
Brownfield fund housing so so we still
have the same red tape the same
processes and we do have a particular
difficulty that is very much associated
with the North and that is the value of
land if I may be positive and say one
good thing of one of many
um is that adult education budget that
has worked and I was looking at figures
um just before I came to give evidence
and it does look really promising that
we're managing because we know our
communities to reach those furthest away
from education to really make a
difference to those furthest away from
jobs and skills and employment and we
can be agile as well so when bus
operators were telling me that the
reason why the bus didn't come was
because they couldn't they didn't have
enough drivers we could put on driver
training and we can be agile with
businesses and also widening access
which is really important to leveling up
so where free training was for those on
women the wages we could widen it to the
real living wage so opening that up to
further opportunities so that we can get
those good skills and that great skilled
Workforce for the businesses that want
to flourish in West Yorkshire so in
conclusion there's good and bad but um
it is a a step in the right direction
but Michael Gove needs the support of
the whole of government
okay and just get a plug-in I think the
driver training programs that have been
I think very welcome in West Yorkshire
are actually being coordinated by a firm
called realize who actually based in my
constituency
the other day so I'll get that plug in
at the beginning
right okay Andy Street um do you agree
with that that view that some things are
working but others still need a bit more
effort to make them work yep that's fair
uh so I probably say that your inquiry
is very well timed because the white
paper was I think the strong view of the
Mayors was incredibly well intentioned
but there's still some outcomes that we
still need to see so the white paper
paper talked in the funding area which
really is the critical issue is this
going to lead to sufficient cash for
doing what we have to do it talks about
funding simplification which is
definitely right and we've seen after
that we've seen the chancellor talk
about a consolidating funding statement
uh or funding settlement sorry for a
mayoral combined authorities in future
spending reviews so there's very clear
evidence that the drive is in the right
direction but what we still need to see
is actually some Devolution of Taxation
power so it's retaining existing tax
that elusive point of fiscal Evolution
so that's something that's very very
necessary and I think under
consideration by the chancellor at the
moment on the uh what's gone well what's
not gone well some departments have
really embraced uh Devolution both with
towers and cash and I'd have to say we
find the Department of Transport overall
pretty good on that and the recent
settlement the city region sustainable
transport settlement would be a good
example there are other areas where
we've still got to win that type of
confidence and we might come to some of
those later on
since the white paper and have things
actually moved on I mean we're actually
making progress practically
is that for me Clive yeah yes yeah sorry
um yes I think they have
um so the white paper promised
um what they called a Trailblazer deal
with the West Midlands and greater
Manchester and Andy's team and my team
are very much in productive
conversations with the government at the
moment and I think there's a time frame
of the end of January
um that we're Loosely working to to see
if that can be signed off so a new
Devolution deal early in the new year I
think would be a real boost for uh
Devolution in England and obviously the
government are looking at other
Devolution deals in other places as well
so what I would say really to agree with
with Andy and Tracy
um the the white people was good if we
remember the criticism pre-michel gove's
arrival it was that leveling up had
never been properly uh defined well he
did Define it and the white paper was
something that we could all uh get
behind but it was words and it's
translating the words into Deeds that is
more difficult and I think Andy was just
touching on this as was Tracy the the
Trailblazer and the nature of what we
agree with the government at the end of
January I think will determine you know
to what extent the government as an as a
a hole isn't is wedded to Devolution so
there's two areas I would pick out at uh
skills and transport because actually if
we don't devolve more more quickly over
both of those areas I think the regional
economy will be at risk it's clear that
um the economy in the north of England
is very much at risk but through
inadequate transport at the moment you
can see that you can feel it uh it's
it's not it's not good enough and
therefore we need more control over that
whole system so that we can protect
ourselves from some of the risks that
we're we're facing but similarly skills
I think the the call we all hear from
our businesses is the kind of concern
around the supply of talent and we need
to be able to ensure that we have that
um if you like that that Talent pipeline
as strong as we can make it and skills
is an area where I think
um we have to see progress otherwise the
regional economy I think will be will be
at risk going forward so those would be
the two acid tests if you like of the
Trailblazer dealers as far as I'm
concerned and uh you know we're we're
hopeful for a positive conclusion but we
still don't yet know quite what the
government will put on the table
right let's move on and one of the
issues of being raised with this is the
whole issue of competitive bidding
um as opposed to
um simple funding allocations
um I think Andrew little you want to
explore that with the mess yes Jim and
thanks very much uh as as Clive says we
've touched on this quite a bit uh as a
as a committee I wonder if all three of
you could tell us um how much you've
spent both financially and on in time
terms on competitive bidding processes
over the years and with those ones that
you've been unsuccessful in has there
been good or not good feedback from the
government departments uh in question
Tracy well I think it's going to be
interesting when the Secretary of State
comes to your Committee in the new year
to also ask the Secretary of State how
much has been spent by government on
assessing bids because it's hard to
quantify because
um hours spent are spent on various
things
running programs that are already up up
and running whilst also preparing
competitive bids but there's a couple of
strands to that
one is that Devolution and the erosion
of local Authority budgets has meant
that fewer staff are meant to do more
bids
um there are bids for example in the
leveling up
um leveling up three which we'll come to
where um the rmca is encouraged to bid
in for transport but because we've got
crsts it's unlikely we're going to get
it but we're spending time because we
have to um bid
um the investment zones we prepared
um uh suggestions and then obviously a
government's Minds were changed there's
a whole sequence of competitive bidding
pots
that are taking up far too much time are
inefficient and for example having to
bid for 2.5 million for the rural
elements of the UK SPF 2.5 million
pounds we're bidding and that that bid
has got to be signed off by three
government departments this is just a
waste of our time now there is that the
opportunity I think from government in
on the back of the Trailblazers giving
funding settlements to MCAS to just get
on with it we know our communities we
know what needs to be delivered we can
be held to account as we are doing today
in front of select committees Public
Accounts committee however you wish us
to be held to account but this is just
not working it is a waste of money and
time and also those areas of deprivation
those local authorities whose budgets
have been absolutely slashed are behind
others in the queue because they just
don't have those resources so it's it's
just not working and if I may also say
when we got
um City region sustainable transport
settlement that we had to bid for
um uh we were also then held to account
by uh number 10 advisors coming for 200
miles from London to my office to tell
me whether we could have a grass roof on
on a bus station and what color the bins
are so we've got through the bidding
process and still there are hands
meddling
um fortunately that person doesn't um uh
isn't isn't a longer in post but I still
am so we continue doing the good work to
deliver for the people of West Yorkshire
but this bidding process if there is one
thing the committee could take away from
this session
the bidding process is ineffective
inefficient it's expensive it doesn't
deliver and it's also subject to
ministerial changes in the weather which
is not good for the North and it's not
good for the UK
when you've not been successful with a
bid for one reason or another have you
felt that government departments have
come back to you to explain why or just
said no sorry you don't get that one
well if I may just use an example the
mayor of South Yorkshire is not here but
when Dan Jarvis was the mayor they put
in for the bus Improvement plan the
b-sip we were really lucky we got 70
million they didn't get a penny and I I
asked you know how what was the feedback
and very little feedback people just
move on it's just not good enough and
and the goal posts are changing all the
time as we saw with investment zones so
we know our communities we know how to
deliver on the government's pledges and
the government's commitment to leveling
up give us the powers the tools and the
money to do it
thank you and uh Andy street now same
question
um can you tell us how much you've spent
money and time on competitive bidding
over the years that you've been in
office and when you have been
unsuccessful have you had any useful
feedback from government departments
yeah so Andrew I'll try to be brief
because there's lots of questions uh
Tracy's covered the efficiency piece but
I want to take your question really from
a philosophical point of view if you
don't mind
um because the point at stake here is
what's the principle of devolution
surely the principle is that there is a
direct election in I think each of our
cases amongst nearly three million
people we're put in place we lay out our
plans before but then what happens
despite all of that the decision making
actually still rests in London that is
not Devolution it goes against the
principle of better decisions are taken
closer to the scene of the action and so
I think the real issue here is if you
trust people with these roles and then
you hold them to account with the
electric directly then actually you need
to entrust them to take the right
decisions not in a sense have their
proposals marked by civil servants and
ministers in London and just this might
seem a cheeky thing to say but I do feel
this very strongly it seems to me there
has to be better value added from
government officials looking at issues
that are of much greater significant for
the country than frankly how relatively
small sums of money are spent across
each of our regions
I mean and I think that philosophical
Point's very important part of what all
this is about so in terms of value added
I'm reading slightly between your lines
there andy that you haven't particularly
had much added value in terms of
feedback
if I'm very honest and I suspect you've
got and I suspect and I don't mean this
to be critical I just meant to be
descriptive you might have the wrong
Witnesses for this point because I think
we all lead authorities that have
actually got sophisticated
um uh Executives we've done very well
from the competitive bidding process I
can add up the total value that we've
brought in uh but I was with members of
the LGA last week and they were joking
at me that the system suits you at the
moment Andy that may be true so I I
personally cannot complain about how
we've done from it and when we haven't
had a good outcome the feedback has been
reasonable
um but I actually think there's a much
broader Point than that thank you so
Andy Burnham same same questions to you
well I was going to say something
similar to Andy because it probably is
local authorities that feel the
frustration of this uh more than us
there is
as Tracy has said an example of a
combined Authority losing out from a
bidding process but by and large you
know we we would say return from from
having submitted a bid I don't have the
figure that you were you were looking
for but what I do have is a figure from
the University of Sheffield who did some
analysis across local government and
they found that 90 of bids for
competitive funds were prepared by
outside Consultants so I think the the
bill without having the figure is
massive and it's money that just goes
straight straight out the door with with
not a huge amount of benefit for for the
residents of those areas particularly
where the bids are not successful and
for me you know if somebody was in
national government now working more
within the world of local government
I I think it implies that a very poor
mindset on the part of Whitehall a sort
of lack of awareness of what's been done
to local government over the years in
the local government of of lost funds so
they've their capability uh has been
reduced and you know all councils are
finding it harder and harder to to have
a capability within to to bring schemes
forward they're then being asked to use
that reduced resource to bid when
they're not guaranteed that it will be
successful and as I've said incurring
huge financial costs as a result of that
without providing a service necessarily
or or a result for residents but then
there's the opportunity cost you know
all the time that is spent that spent on
that and what I'd like to check at this
point is just point to what is a
potential solution
so in the Autumn statement the
government very helpfully pointed to the
idea of a single settlement that it is
considering for greater Munster and the
West Midlands combined Authority as part
of the um the Trailblazer deal so in
effect a block grant similar to uh
Scotland and Wales where there is much
greater flexibility
um to um to to use that that funding but
as Tracy said before it absolutely
should come with strong accountability
and I would be more than happy to attend
any Select Committee of the house to to
account for delivery against the
outcomes that we hopefully will jointly
agree with the government so I would say
that is exciting if Whitehall is showing
its willingness to change and move
towards funding of that kind it would
mean we're all much focused on more
focused on delivery rather than bidding
and that can only be a good thing and
we'd use public money better I think at
the moment Whitehall is making Town Hall
waste money
that's what that's that's what bidding
does whereas we need to be working
towards a system where everyone doesn't
have to plead for money everywhere
should get funding more based on on
needs I I would say uh and that I think
is is a big change that that really
should come through and I hope this
select committee inquiry which is Andy
Street said is very welcome the timing
of it I I hope you know we could all
together on a cross-party basis move
towards a system where national
government trust local government more
and gives it the ability to deliver
rather than tying it up in in all of
these endless competitive processes no
if we if we do see that that really that
really will be uh extraordinary I have
to say uh so we'll look forward to it
um but um would you say in that world
where we if we do end up getting to a
sort of single pot sort of uh
Grant as it were
would there be any place for bidding
type pots announcements from central
government or would it be better just to
get away from all that altogether
I guess at the margins for an
exceptional
um uh decision so obviously channel four
was an example but I don't think any of
us found that particularly
um uh productive process you know we'd
rather the decision was made and it was
just given because you know it just
takes a lot of time but you could look
also at the headquarters of Great
British Railways you know again a sort
of you know long drawn out process where
a lot of money is spent on campaigns by
various places and you know it's not
necessarily the best use of resources in
these in these times so I I wouldn't say
there's no role is what I would say but
I think we need to get away from this
idea of winners and losers in a bidding
contest and one of the points I wanted
to make today chair was to to start
thinking about leveling up as becoming a
long-term permanent mission that is
enshrined in in the way the country
works as opposed to it being a bit ad
hoc and one area wins and another one
loses I I've been looking at the German
Constitution recently and in the German
Constitution there is something called
the basic law and the basic law requires
that there is an equivalent of living
standards between the lender the regions
of Germany now can you imagine if we had
such a a provision in this country how
different life would be for people in
the north of England it would be very
different indeed and I think we've got
to move leveling up now to a more kind
of permanent long-term Mission uh that
the country Works towards where local
government and combined authorities has
passed that I just trusted to deliver
and you know I I just think the um the
country would benefit from that
long-term approach where all areas get
get I I I do an amount of funding they
can work with over the long term to plan
for the economic uh and social
regeneration of their areas and I just
think we the country would be in a
better place if we had that thank you
Andy Street no role for bidding
continued role or just on the margins as
Andy Andy Bernie I agree with that Andy
said it's just on the uh on the margins
but as you give me the microphone back
can I just mention one other thing which
I think is then uh a very important
point in terms of what's expected of
combined authorities for making the big
step towards this um this single pot
settlement which is really the Utopia
that we've been talking about since
Michael has funded his first paper and
people think we want to sort of rob the
bank and run away not so we're
absolutely up for
um as Andy B said the accountability
framework and to give you a really good
example of something that's worked very
well for us our housing deal that we
struck in 2018 when Sajid Javid was
Secretary of State it had performance
criteria in it and we only got the
second third fourth tranche is if we
delivered them so the cash was already
all there the decisions on how we spent
it are with us but the outcomes had to
be subject to scrutiny and I do think
that is a mature model that we are very
willing to uh develop for other areas
thank you Tracy I I agree with both
undies that on the margins 10
potentially where you could see
Innovation excitement a bit of
um you know new thinking R D
um I think yeah uh it can't be the way
forward though we have to have that as
as the two undies have said that funding
part and if if I may just very quickly
say I'm I do welcome the report that
came out a couple of days ago that
government are looking at widening
Trailblazers because we have been around
for a while as a as a combined Authority
whilst I'm maybe a new mayor the combine
Authority has been um proving it it can
spend
um on budget and um and to time for many
years so I am hoping that will be
widened out to MCAS that do deliver
y thanks Jim Mary you've got a
supplementary thank you thank you chair
it's such a quick one the criticism from
local authorities very often is around
funding that it's never enough for their
needs
um if we were to move towards a single
pot settlement agreement what would the
criteria be for that single pot to be
agreed
Andy Burnham
thank you Mary well to be agreed uh with
the government so
um I would imagine that we would have
agreements across a range of outcomes
um that you know we would commit to
deliver as part of that that funding
agreement
um and and then we would be held to
account by and I as I said before I and
Tracy said the same we'd be happy to go
before any select committee to account
uh for for that but I think the outcomes
would be more sophisticated than some of
the silo based outcomes that you get
from from from Whitehall you know you
you could have broader uh broader
um things that you were hoping to
achieve for the area or
um or if it was the case that Whitehall
wanted specifics then you know I again I
think we could be trusted to deliver so
one area that I'm interested I mentioned
before as part of the Trailblazer
discussion is skills
I think we need to move towards a very
different skill system
um and actually a system as opposed to a
very fragmented landscape I believe
to make
um this work we need to give all young
people an offer at 16 and that should be
a levels T levels or apprenticeship yeah
we need to bring together
um the system which we can do from from
our perspective and if the government
wanted just part of that to give me a
Target for increasing the number of T
levels which have got a very high level
of support in Greater that would be
absolutely fine Mary absolutely fine and
this is where Devolution I think adds
value to to UK PLC because we can then
really drive the things from this level
uh which we all agree as a country the
things that we we need we need to do
um and you know it also if you look at
in the context of public transport it
could be to increase patronage on on
public transports and set a very clear
Target for for that so I'm up for the
discussion about it if I'm honest and
I'm I don't fear any of that
accountability at all and in fact I
think we'd all find it quite helpful to
be honest to have a very clear set of
things that everyone could you're just
against rather than sometimes you know
in our roles people some people say
you've done nothing or other people say
oh you know you you'd be better to be
said you know here's what you said you
would do and then judge us against it
because I'm confident now that there's a
maturity in in all of these Systems
Great Manchester West Yorkshire and the
West Midlands that means we don't fear
that at all you know we're ready to get
on and do it
okay right can we move on then to look
at the Shared Prosperity fund
um Kate Holden thank you chair
the clothes that is limited flexibility
with the UK shared Prosperity fund do
authorities run the risk of a cliff Edge
we can put that to Andy Street first
you may and thank you for your question
because we've actually been in
correspondence with the minister on this
very Point only the last few weeks
obviously it is good news that the all
the authorities represented and Lead
across the whole country we've had
agreement to our proposals so the cash
will be coming soon but there is a real
issue for example that we can't move
cash between different years and we've
only got a very few months of this year
left but perhaps more significantly to
your question we can't spend money on
the skills and communities element of it
until the third year really precisely
it's a detailed point but I do think
it's a practical point we are seeking
further flexibilities in the fund just
as you described
okay Tracy
um yes I I agree with what Andy said but
I would also just reiterate the issue
for us is that we are losing a third in
comparison to what government have
promised When government said that no
Community would lose money in comparison
to EU fundings UK SPF for West Yorkshire
we've lost over a third which means our
Cliff Edge is is is deep and dangerous
and we are certainly uh going to lose
organizations that work in communities
that work with migrants a particularly
important given the Ukrainian situation
not getting any better it is really
important for us the public field
they've had their pocket picks I'm going
to be really Frank
um they don't feel that government have
been honest and this Cliff Edge is
really damaging now we have tried with
gain share and other powers to team and
ladle to try and support particularly
the employment Hub employee is we don't
want to people to lose their jobs in a
cost of living crisis we're doing all we
can but we are definitely looking at 18
out of 33 live projects potentially
going to the wall
thanks Kate I I think the um the
principle here should be that
share prosperity for should it not be
any way worse than what it's replacing
but I'm afraid it probably is in a
number of respects and Tracy and Andy
have touched on a couple so shall I
introduce
a new element as well to to complete the
picture
the fund that it replaced uh one of is
the European structural investment fund
e s i f and that uh was a seven year a
seven year funding program and obviously
um uh share Prosperity fund does not
give that that level of timeline and if
I could give you a relevant example from
greater Manchester as to why the seven
year
um Horizon was helpful if you look at
something like Innovation and really
building an innovation economy you need
that level of uh that time span if
you're to bring bring projects forward
so in the case of esif it was very
important in bringing through the
national graphene Institute in
Manchester and the graphene engineering
and Innovation Center you know which is
really coming into its own but it was
done because of that longer term
um time frame uh and I would say that
you know the the shared Prosperity from
needs to need to develop a similar
long-term approach with the amount of
funding as Tracy said at least at
European levels and without this impact
on the people and skills element as Andy
Street was saying so I guess it's good
that we're getting to the point now
where allocations are being approved but
uh there are still some structural
deficiencies in shared Prosperity fund
compared to what it's replacing
thanks and if I can just come back to
Andy's street again uh Tracy was saying
uh she couldn't lose a thought what sort
of impact are you expecting
the the numbers are the same across most
of the country actually
um now the argument from the government
is that in time it will come back to
equivalence with uh the collective
so but certainly in the initial period
the transition the numbers are fairly
similar and just like
um uh Tracy described we have been
trying to use other funding that we've
got uh to make good some of those gaps
as well so I don't disagree with what
Tracy said about the numbers
does that put at risk some of the
partnership working with organizations
within your area not at all it's the
converse actually uh it's actually that
uh whether it be uh the lap integration
into the ca whether it be some of the
fundings that local authorities allocate
out I think what's happening is we're
all trying to work in a really
collaborative way and actually the
cooperation locally on how we use this
cash has been good and we've got a
cross-party uh unanimity on how we're
trying to do that
um if I could just add that there is one
one strand of the the
UK SPF which is given from the center
which is multiply which seemed to be
something that was an in answer to a
line in in their budget somewhere from
maybe the chancellor who's now the Prime
Minister and it is it is a lump of money
12 and a half million pound very welcome
thank you for that but it is completely
controlled from the center now it's to
teach numeracy to those furthest away
from education that is not an easy task
people are not going to walk into a
classroom to learn numeracy you have to
surround those students with a different
sort of offer we know what type of
support they need and we can give now
we're doing our bit and we're trying but
this does feel like just another example
of devolution actually being controlled
from the center and if you want numeracy
numbers to improve and we all do give us
that money and we can deal with it and
handle it locally and we can get those
great outcomes for you
when you're dealing with numeracy or
literacy there's a level of confidence
building indeed for beforehand indeed if
you have uh commented on expecting to
lose
a
third
uh what will you have to cut
well I've been sick for losing that
thought yes well certainly as I was
mentioning it looks like 18 of the 33
live projects are at risk we are doing
everything we can there's stronger
families projects the as I said the
migrant project Community grants but
we're doing everything everything we can
to mitigate that but there is a there is
an economic difference to what was
promised to what has been
um allocated to West Yorkshire so from
the
um 120 million we were expecting it's 88
sorry 83 million
and I'm sure you will have an
opportunity to speak to the Secretary of
State about this as well when he comes
before you next year
Andy Burnham uh what are you going to
have to cut to Andy uh to cover for this
shortfall
it's kind of a reduction I guess Kate in
the level of of activity
um we um will uh I think face we do have
some concerns around uh the people and
skills elements and a reduction in
availability of support uh also
potentially scaling back some of our
infrastructure Ambitions
um it's it's a challenge
um but you know obviously we're looking
at how we can use some of the benefits
within the funding and one of the
benefits could be that that the
requirement the lack of a requirement
for match funding which did exist before
does allow it potentially to be used
more uh more flexibly so it's not all
bad okay you know there is there is some
that's some benefit here but I think you
know it at this time uh what we should
be seeing is obviously more investment
in in skills and infrastructure uh and
uh we are planning on a reduced A
reduced sort of time Horizon basically
as a result of some of the changes that
have come through and then you add in
the the shorter term nature of the fund
it kind of works against that longer
term planning
Andy three
I think we just need to be precise about
what this word cut means so let me just
explain what's actually happening
because
um whilst I agreed with Tracy earlier on
that it's about equivalence of money uh
what is actually happening schemes that
had a finite end date that were European
funded and they always knew they had a
finite end date are running to that end
date they are not being cut prematurely
they carry
yes not like what is not likely to
happen is that there won't be an equip
necessarily be an equivalent replacement
for them that is what the question is no
re no cut to an existing project and
this is tough love but it is true that
if you take on a contract even in the
old lap days when the leps are
responsible for this there was no
guarantee of that project having a new
funding around the the East all the
European funds had finite time window
now it is true that there isn't the same
amount of money particularly in the
skills area to commission new projects
so that's the risk and what we are
trying to do look at other budgets for
example are the skills funding to be
able still to commission them that's the
Practical issue that the projects are
running to their agreed end date in our
case actually we're not finding a
difficulty of infrastructure because
other funding has come in to more than
make up for the uh for the
infrastructure elements so the real
question is where is the funding for the
skills project coming from
thank you okay can we move on now to the
leveling up fund
um Paul thank you chair
um when Michael Gove recently appeared
to our committee and gave evidence he
noted that he had an intention to have a
third round of the leveling up fund
um firstly do you think there should be
one and secondly
um what should it what should it focus
on give us your Christmas card wish list
or Christmas wish list and first Tracy
please well thank you
um well currently we're still waiting
for the outcomes of leveling up uh two
round obviously more money for our
region is incredibly welcome
um but we are facing a cost of living
crisis and there it does feel slightly
um eccentric that local authorities
having to bid into leveling up funds in
order to deliver what they used to
deliver so for example in Halifax
um the they were successful in leveling
up fund bid for a new Leisure Center
which now they're having to pause
because
costs escalated to such a point that
they couldn't deliver on government
timetables which were which are always
incredibly stretching
um and I I will say the department have
been really good working with Halifax
and calderdale Council to try and find a
solution but this can't be the way
forward that we're just bidding in for
EV charging points for for leisure
centers for toilets where where what
should be done is is to Andy Burnham's
point that local government the cuts to
local government have been so deep over
decades that there isn't there is no fat
left so they're having to bid in against
each other for money that should be
already in their budgets kirkles for
example has lost 60 percent of its
funding since 2010 so of course their
focus is on adult social services and
and Children's Services they they're
having to bid for the stuff that they
would normally offer so my my Christmas
wish list would be well certainly to um
index link gain share because at the
moment that's not index linked so as
every year goes by and of course with
rampant inflation it's worth it's worth
less and less but my top of my Santa
list is please do give us those
um those allocations of funding holders
to account on the outcomes in West
Yorkshire we already have three scrutiny
committees which is quite unique for
MCAS across the country we're held to
accounts continually and we'll continue
to do so but we have to get out of these
funding pot bids thank you um Andy
Burnham third round yes no and what
would you use it for what should it
focus on
uh well if I could play back to you the
main frustration that I hear and I'm
sure Tracy and Andy uh here uh from from
local authorities is the sometimes the
lack of alignment between the leveling
up front and other funds such as the
townsfund and the High Street fund and
all of this gets gets very very
confusing I would say at least
consolidate all of those uh all of those
things but I would go further and I
would do exactly what Tracy just
proposed which is
put this funding back within uh core
local Authority funding because here
people are bidding the things they used
to be able to do I mean an example uh
Tracy uh gave there is a changing places
toilet program I mean
why is there a national bidding fund for
that you know surely local authorities
should have the money within their their
Capital budgets uh to to make those kind
of changes to their to their local areas
and I think we did see a trend
I don't know why exactly it was all done
like this perhaps it was you know the
kind of awarding of it the warding of a
bid allows a press release to be issued
and you know an MPS have said that they
got this money out of the government I
it felt that some of that was was behind
this this bidding culture and I do think
rather than just accept it as part of
the landscape that we're in I I think we
need to start to challenge it and say
local government just needs to be
trusted to get on with the job a bit
more rather than pleading all the time
for scraps off the table and actually
for the money that it used to have
anyway to to build Leisure centers or or
public toilets I I really do think we
would see quicker and better delivery
and in my experience again from my time
in whitehallton to the five or so years
I've done this job I am actually clear
that that Whitehall has no real right to
do this to local government because by
making everybody bid it implies a lack
of trust and they're constantly making
people prove themselves whereas it in my
experience I think uh national
government of all under all colors by
the way waste wastes more money than
local government I think local
government is very very lean actually uh
and uses things because it's closer to
where things will happen it makes better
decisions often about a local project
and I do think rather while we can
improve the leveling up fund and
integrating it with the town's fund and
the high streets fund for instance I
don't think we should accept that this
should be a permanent part of the
landscape I think we've got to get back
to a point where local government in
England has more capability to do more
for itself deliver more quickly rather
than always having to jump through
Whitehall hoops
thank you very much and Andy Street
please
so I think in a sense you've just heard
it from the other two this is almost the
textbook example of the principle that
we were talking about in the first round
of question so this is you know there's
been some welcome Investments here
nobody's going to sniff at that but you
come to is it the right way of doing
things and I would say categorically not
what we need to get to is the trust that
a settlement for a region or a local
Authority would bring about and just let
me try to explain one other feature that
we didn't pull out earlier as to why
leveling up fund bits are incredibly
random from colleges in Wolverhampton to
swimming pools in Birmingham to high
streets it's all sorts of things and of
course the local authorities have really
reasons why they bid for that but is
there a real strategic plan Behind These
either locally or centrally there is not
and surely what we should be looking for
is a strategy around how a Revival of a
city or a region can come about which
brings together the different elements
and has got one plan different funding
streams lead into that plan and my
strong argument would be the local
authorities working with it to combine
it can do that if it has sufficient
funding to enable it to do this this
random approach won't get the best bang
for the book thank you very much I just
I'm conscious of time I just want to ask
a very quick question to the three of
you um Tracy mentioned the example in
Halifax with costs going up
um if you've been successful in bidding
on any of the previous rounds can you
give any examples in your area where
um there's been pressure or risk due to
the inflation repressures that we
currently have so if I could you
mentioned Halifax Tracy can I mention
can I ask you yeah I mean Halifax is a
perfect example four million pounds of
escalation but the timetables stay the
same a timetable of delivery
um it just can't be done and I know that
there is some flexing but we have to if
if we sold on this bidding process we
have to work as partners rather than the
man in Whitehall who knows best and we
have to hit that deadline or the project
doesn't get the money and can be
withdrawn almost overnight so I think
that is a good example that hopefully
will be resolved thank you um Andy
Burnham any inflationary pressures on
your mid well I I actually had the
Leisure Center in calderdale as my
example as well in my briefing so I
don't think I've got an example the
Steal My Leisure Center
we're not trying to annexwhere Yorkshire
just yet maybe one day that's Facebook
what I can give you is the figure
um I think came from an ippr report
which said that as a result of inflation
the leveling up fund is effectively
reduced by 340 Million by 2526 so I
think what you're going to find is a a
kind of maybe not as devastating as
putting a whole Leisure Center on hold
but I think lots of projects will it
will be a bit up in the air let's say
um because they're going to have to find
a bit of extra local resource to to meet
that meet that Gap and possibly a
slightly longer longer time frame but I
I can't I'm sorry give you a direct
tangible example from greatest monster
that's absolutely fine thank you and
Andy Street please as far as I know none
of our projects have been put on whole
old but the process that Andy's just
explained is what's happening every
single project whether it be leveling up
from crsts you name it we've got
inflationary pressures in each one of
them and the local authorities or the ca
we've got paper on it on Friday actually
I know Tracy's already taken one are all
having to look at additional resources
to supplement every grant that we've had
thank you very much thank you Jeff let's
move on to metrics and data and how uh
need is assessed to marriage yeah thank
you chair um if I come to you first
because I believe that you're leaving a
few minutes and there has been a great
deal thank you for reminding everybody
I'm sorry there has been a real great
deal of discussion around the use of
metrics about what data should be used
and how need can be judged evidence so
far
um has noted that need According to some
is not mean made Fairly effectively
especially Barnsley Borough Council um
questioned the current use of data so
can you tell uh tell us what metrics
should be used to determine need and why
so it's a very precise question around
the metrics for the leveling up fund and
I think what I've already said to you
rather sort of implies I don't think
that's the right way of going about it
at all I think it should be something
much more strategic about the overall
approach I've looked in preparation for
this question at the way in which the
data was taken for the leveling up fund
and I actually find it hard to criticize
in principle I'm sure Others May
disagree with it but but it was tried to
be done around a basket of measures that
seemed particularly reasonable to me so
if you don't mind I'd like to make just
one other point about the way the data
is mentioned worked and this what
appeared to us to be very harsh Judgment
of some urban areas that were judged in
category two or three Coventry was
originally two solid holes originally
three both have within them
most deprived in the country and we felt
that it was very harsh the way they were
effectively excluded for funding but the
basket idea I didn't find that that too
difficult to come to terms with thank
you Annie Burnham same question to you
sir
well I would just want to say that we
very strongly welcome the uh
recommendation in the loving of white
paper to improve uh the provision of
sub-national data uh to combined
authorities and local authorities and I
think there was a suggestion of creating
a statistical service
sub-national data strategy but we're
we're still still waiting on that I
think there was an idea of a spatial
data unit
um so all of those proposals were very
welcome but I'm we're not aware of any
progress on them and so if the committee
could push on that I think it would be
beneficial for for everybody because
obviously there is data held in
Whitehall departments that that we need
to know about and and yet we don't at
the moment so um it was an important
commitment to the white paper but as of
yet we don't think there has been any
tangible progress on it
Tracy yeah I would agree with Andy
street that the basket idea is sensible
we have our own intelligence team in in
the MCA and we have a state of the
region report it uses a basket of 40
different headline indicators
um but I do think there is a lack of
clarity about the purity of decision
making around who gets what when and I
think
um whether that's looking at it again
around indices of multiple deprivation
is is that one that should be used in
you know more widely or taken into
account more deeply
um I think I think when it comes to data
we all have to be data driven and
evidence-led and it can't Nestle
politics often gets in the way doesn't
it but I think I think data gives us the
truth of the situation and I think we
should be responding to deprivation and
to opportunities to deliver on
governments expect affected outcomes and
we are on the ground and we can help
government do that and and if the
correct metrics are not used for future
leveling up funds what impact will this
have on communities across the UK well
it erodes trust in politicians it erodes
trust in society people don't feel heard
or valued and this is why Devolution is
so powerful that local leaders can speak
as the voice of the public that they
represent and I really do believe that
when it looks like there's some sort of
um behind the scenes decision making
that isn't clear people lose faith in
politicians and anger bills and that's
when you have problems
um with lack of democracy people feel
disengaged from politics I think it's an
opportunity if you get it right to show
that you're listening to the public and
you're responding to need Andy Street do
you agree with Tracy
um yes I think I've already said that
frankly okay thanks nothing to happen
yeah all right thank you not necessarily
on everything before you go no we do
agree on a lot though no but we're all
in the M10 together we all share the
particular problems we're all feeling
the pain
would you like to add anything
just just
stand it
um the difference in per capita funding
between the best funded local
authorities in the country and the
lowest is
um is is getting on for 200 pounds so
909 pounds per head in the best funded
691 of available uh funding per capita
in the lowest funded
um you know that's quite a gap and I
think it gets worse the more that
council tax is expected to Bear the
strain of local of local funding
um because obviously the some of the
poorer areas
um have less ability to raise funding
through uh through council tax
um so you know it's it's quite a gap and
I think it's it's it's getting to a
point where that that's becoming to way
too big from my point of view
right uh I want to move on there the
issue of funding inequalities and say uh
and this tree you have to leave us now
or can you stay a little bit longer
I I'm uh I should leave you I don't if
you don't mind Clive I did say five
o'clock yeah rather than Breaking the
rhythm of the next question I should
probably okay well thank you for coming
to take my leave thank you for your uh
thank you very much cheers
right and move on to the shoe that's
just been raised actually funding uh and
inequalities uh Natalie thank you sir
and um and I do want to actually build
on that
um those remarks that they just made
Andy in relation to the extent to which
council tax is uh is is now bearing a
transfer effectively a financial
transfer from from National to local
within that context and both of you have
touched on this a bit but I just wanted
to explore it a bit further to what
extent do you think that the the funding
for leveling up is intended to meet some
of that shortfall in funding for local
government or is it additional and I
know we've mentioned sort of the toilets
and the Leisure centers but obviously in
relation to transport that might be a
slightly different uh you know that
might be different in in your minds in
terms of whether that's additional or
replacement
um who wants to go first Andy
well I I think it's a good way of
thinking it about it isn't it that there
are Basics that all councils should be
funded to provide and they shouldn't be
discretionary I don't think um uh
funding for uh Leisure culture those
kind of things that there should just be
enough in the budget for all areas to to
provide and I go back to that point I
made near the start at Natalie the point
about
um
equivalence of living standards in the
German Constitution I think we need to
get our own version of that you know
what what is the kind of British version
of the German Constitution where we can
guarantee an equivalence of basic
infrastructure and standards in all
parts of the country and not have what
can be quite you know a massive
difference actually from one part of the
country to another when it then comes to
sort of things that are additional to
that basic infrastructure then I think
that would be a more appropriate use of
of level leveling up funding and bidding
if that if that makes sense I think
we've got to we've got a very very
confused picture when it comes to to
local funding in this country and it's
not producing a sort of a fairness
across all of the different different
regions and I think we need to if we
can't really go much further without
without unpacking this because you know
the frustration for me is we've not
really seen as many visible signs of
leveling up as we would have liked but I
you know I very much support the agenda
but I would like to see more progress
however
I think by putting leveling up front and
center as the government did I think it
has unlocked a cry for regional fairness
that isn't going to go away and if
anything is only going to get louder and
louder and I think the message you're
getting from all three of us this
afternoon is you are more likely to
achieve a a leveling of living standards
across the country where funding is not
discretionary or competitive but where
it's baked in to what local areas have
got and and it's there for the long term
um and and you know that that is how I
would say we would start to erode some
of the inequalities in health or in
other areas if if you want to look at it
look at it that way so you know I think
leveling up was the right theme at the
right time and I give the government
credit for that but I think it has to
become a kind of long-term National
Mission and we have to move it from this
space where it's been which is a bit
discretionary and a bit hit and miss and
ad hoc so something that is much more
you know hardwired into the into the way
the country works
said and I think
to build on his point what is actually
leveling up and isn't it about giving
everybody across the UK the same basic
offer of access to a library access to
decent transport access to a Leisure
Center where you can you know exercise
or take your kids we all should have
that that that expectation that wherever
we live those basic needs are going to
be
fulfilled and we have seen and
particularly I would say across the
north the cost of living crisis
inflation what used to be that safety
net is now absolutely a thread it used
to be local authorities would provide
services that if you were on
um if you were at work you could go to
the Leisure Center and have a swim and
the you know the local Authority would
support you or you would go to the
library or have a course now
it's bed Banks it's it's energy Banks
it's food banks it's people living day
to day we have a job as locally elected
leaders to reset that balance and
working with government we are we are up
for this but it is in the landscape and
I do have some numbers where
Leeds is looking at it has lost 263
million each year from 2011 to 2023
calderdale having to find 120 million of
savings they found Savings of 120
million Bradford uh budget reduction of
310 million it's just been eroded year
on year and now these parts are supposed
to fill that in so we've got the city
region sustainable transport settlement
and a large chunk of that is potholes is
funding to fill potholes this is
something that local authorities used to
do
um as part of their bread and butter and
now we're bidding to to to provide that
infrastructure it's about dignity and I
think when we talk about leveling up
it's about fairness and dignity so so
just sort of building from that because
of because my my uh error is obviously
covered by Kent County Council were put
in concerns about
um potentially facing bankruptcy and you
know my area is also an area in Dover
and deal that has very significant areas
of deprivation that hasn't benefited
from some of the funds that you have
have described in the same way so I I'm
just I'm just very keen to understand I
mean all three of you as Mayors have set
out how successful you've been in
bidding and how and effective your
particular authorities are in being able
to bid
um Andy you you've been mayor since 2017
obviously Tracy you're a newer mayor
but over over the period that we've had
the marrow combined system we've
actually seen those inequalities
um according to the ippr
um get get worse
um particularly uh around health and
sickness
um in in the north east and and I
wondered to what extent you think that
the Ambitions that you have set out as
mayor are achievable within the context
of the leveling up Vision that you
described for your single part and
alternative funding yeah um well you're
looking at me so um I I think of course
it is possible but we have to have that
arm that's tied behind our back untied
we have to be able to deliver we don't
wasting time coming back to Whitehall
foot you know with a begging Bowl we
could get on and help deliver now I know
Devolution is a way to try and resolve
some of the problems of inequality but
it can't it it can't be that you erode
the finances for local Authority and
then you expect Mayors to patch it up
it's got to be a 360 approach from
government and I do think their
commitment to leveling up is an
opportunity to be incredibly bold and to
have a new contract with the public and
say we believe in Devolution and we are
going to make sure that wherever you
live you get those same life chances as
somebody who lives in the South only
transport all of us no no of course not
but the areas areas where people have
had for example on transport three times
as much as spent per head in the
southern in London to the north and
that's been happening for decades so we
have such a long way to go in order to
get that Equalization that you obviously
so need for your area yeah not all parts
of the South uh need more transport we
need more transport investment Andy Andy
so you have been you have been a long
time so yeah what is it that you need to
drive this equality agenda
it's it's that
um long-term uh approach that I was
talking about before Natalie um and the
single settlement the block grant really
would help help us I think the reason
being the the potential of devolution is
to join the dots on the ground between
the White Hall silos so we can make
things make sense here because we can
bring it all together into into a
coherent whole and if you look at Health
Devolution in Greater Manchester because
obviously we had that five years ago
what we have shown is actually we can
move the dial so there's a study in the
landsat recently of the first five years
of Health Devolution in great monster it
concluded that life expectancy had
increased here faster than expected and
it had increased most in our most
deprived communities
and it what it said was the reason why
that had happened was the high degree of
alignment both between public bodies but
also between our public bodies and the
community and voluntary sector what
we're doing here is adopting a
mission-based approach to things for
instance on rough sleeping where we've
really massively reduced uh the level of
rough sleeping over the last over the
last five years with plenty of support
from government which we're grateful for
I guess it's that ability here to join
the dots around people and places and
make it all make make sense and I would
say you get a much more efficient use of
government funding in that in that
scenario rather than you know the old
the old way of working so we we have
definitely moved faster on things I mean
I funded things here though outside of
the white hole system completely such as
a free bus pass for our 16 to 18 year
olds which I would say is is hugely
raising aspiration across greater
Manchester as I mentioned before about
all young people having a pathway at 16
a level T level apprenticeship that free
bus pass really get is their means to
getting to those opportunities at the
end of the end of school so I
and this is working you know Devolution
in England is a success story it's but
it's in its very earliest days and it
could be so much more if you look at
Leeds Birmingham Manchester there is an
energy and a confidence in these cities
that we've not seen in a in a long long
time if you look at the skyline of city
center Manchester it tells a real story
about uh confidence about you know a
place that's going somewhere knowing
upwards actually
um you know these there is so much
potential in these places uh and if you
the more you back them the more they
will deliver back to ukpl PLC I'm
absolutely sure about that Natalie thank
you very much thank you chair right
thank you uh moving on to the issues
have already mentioned the
infrastructure and transport in Ben yeah
thanks and I'll just stay with Andy
because he forgot to mention Liverpool
later their major city even saw Steve
vladen be on the phone the next five
minutes
he's just texted me and he's just cut
him off he's cut him out of his will
he's still smarting from losing a DJ
battle
[Laughter]
so we're on the earth only subject to
transports and these are part of
ensuring the successful leveling up is
arguably dependence on maintaining and
improving infrastructure across the
country the white paper states that
better stands for open attack people
business finance culture also physical
infrastructure and vital to improving
conductivity so transplant transport
networks will also be called drivers of
this Mission so in your experience does
this thing to do and how do we achieve a
transport Network to North deserves and
not the shambles we have now and we
won't mention the terrains yeah well Ian
I'm going to answer that in two two
parts if you like one positive one one
less so the positive is that the white
paper
correctly set a goal of london-style
public transport for all parts of
England by 2030. and the reason why I
say correctly because we've been calling
for that and I know Steve in Liverpool
has called call for the same and I think
we're we're perhaps a little bit ahead
of Liverpool and Leeds on this but we're
all working together on it we're all
working to that uh to that goal
um so obviously I've taken the decision
to put buses back under public control
the reason that's so important is
because you can then start to integrate
boss tram hire bike and introduce that
daily cap over all All Transport so that
London style vision is actually just a
couple of years away now you know we
will have integrated
um the buses with the trams by the start
of 2025. you know all of it will be back
under public control by that point and
then I think you you've got a very
different offer for uh for the traveling
public and the aim is part of the
Trailblazer is to then get more control
over Overland rail as tfl did in London
where we then have commuter rail
Services inside that daily cap if you
like it and you know where it you know
there's like a tfgm rail service that
that people then can can use to get
around and all of that will make public
transport much more uh competitive when
it comes to the cost of traveling around
by car and I think we'll we'll finally
break the domination of the car in large
parts of the Northwest so this is a
difficult Journey that we're on at this
particular month in time but Grace
manager is right in it and my message to
the government is please work with us as
a partner on this and they are largely
we've had a very positive response
um you know we
uh need that support as we go through
this because if we successfully do this
in Greater Manchester we will help
create the template that others will
then use yourselves in Liverpool
um Tracy in Leeds you know there's no
there's no we're all wanting the same
thing and we all want to help each other
get to the get to the same place I guess
then the the slightly less positive
point is is to talk about Rail and the
state of state of Railways at the moment
because in many ways they're dragging us
down
um if you look at City Center Manchester
at the moment look at our five train
stations Piccadilly Oxford Road
deansgate Salford Central Manchester
Victoria they've barely seen any
investment
um for the last 20 or so years the
infrastructure between them is
absolutely at saturation point it's it's
it's creaking Victorian infrastructure
the services well that we all know don't
we they're just they've just gone
completely backwards you know we're
coming up a decade since George
Osborne's Northern Powerhouse speech
kicked all of this off and and he said
that rail had to be the heart of a
vision for the north Powerhouse in that
decade rail Services have gone backwards
uh and it's really really hurting us at
the moment so it's because of as Tracy
was saying the fragility of the northern
um Railway system uh that means you know
we're suffering uh more than other parts
of the country so there is a template
for how you can build a better future
but it's frustrating when at that same
time parts of our transport system uh
are going going backwards I think Ian
that the the the the motto of the story
from merseyrail where you have a railway
under more local control and I hope you
agree with this is devolve local control
of Transport Systems delivers better
systems absolutely because it brings an
accountability that isn't there in the
National uh Railway system and it allows
an integration of of that transport with
other with other modes of modes of
transport and for me this is absolutely
the way to go but the government needs
to back it as Tracy said you know we
can't do it without subsidy London
didn't build its transport system
without a subsidy over the years well
the north of England won't be able to do
it without subsidy as well so we do need
the government to come in as a partner
was fantastic everything you said there
they're both Investments and you know it
was absolute spots on so well done thank
you thank you but
um Andy and I and and the Mayors are all
in agreement that you can't level up
without having access to jobs and
opportunities and that's all about
transport now uh I think government get
that we need a better transport network
but the it doesn't feel like there's one
particular guiding mind delivering on
particularly around buses we've
staggered from one Cliff Edge to another
with a bus recovery Grant we were
grateful that government extended it but
we are back again in April where there's
going to be a cliff Edge and whilst I've
been able to introduce mayor's fares
which is the two pound cap and the 450
day saver which is increasing patronage
I can't stop bus companies from cutting
routes so people can say oh you know
great fair but there's no boss for me to
get on so we are investigating we've
started the process in the first week of
me becoming mayor we kicked off the
process to look at public control and
the decision to for that will be uh
2024. it's a long process it's
government timetables but it's really
important for us to have that integrated
London style transport Network and if I
may just say I'd like to thank the
transport Minister for the Secretary of
State for transport meeting us the
northern Mayors to talk about the
situation but actually since the
timetable changes on Sunday it's got
even worse how is that possible to be
even worse from TP and Avanti I don't
know but we will be continuing to be the
voice of the traveling public because
you cannot level up
uh anywhere without a transport Network
to get people to jobs opportunities and
colleges and to hear stories of people
missing funerals
um you know not going for that job
interview because they can't get their
students saying I want to go to this
University but I'll have to cross the
pen lines so I'm going to you know go go
somewhere else somewhere I didn't want
to go these decisions are people's
futures and every single person that
can't get that train is impacted so we
are going to continue uh continue that
that campaign
very quickly just just to back up what
Tracy's saying obviously today is the
first day of the new timetable
and so a lot is riding on on this
um we were promised Tracy and I at
transport of the north that this would
be the route to get more stability uh
into the system the figures I have from
midday today uh were transpennine
Express 44 of trains on time and they
canceled or they removed last night I
think over seven I think closer to 100
trains and even then they're only at 44
Avanti
West Coast at midday today 12 on time
now they may be running more services
today out of Manchester to London which
is welcome but 12 on time I mean these
figures are just
um unbelievably bad
yeah absolutely I want to just touch on
the uh desires to improve health Tracy
so how important is it that transporting
places outside London receive the fund
to get need so we can decarbonize Sun
Sports yeah today at all but also
General desires to improve Builders and
they touched on before taking cars off
the road you know the air pollution
sailing my constituencies are pulling
the times it's obviously Keith it's the
key to the level of what we need to do
thank you well the um the leveling up
Bill I think could do with that greater
focus on the climate emergency because
we're not going to level up our
communities if for example in hebden
bridge when communities and homes have
been washed away
um you can't level up when one in 20 a
West Yorkshire they die from air
pollution something related to air
pollution we've got to act swiftly and
at PACE and that's why a transport
system that's the London style system to
get people out of their cars and onto
buses and trains is so important to get
Freight off the road and onto onto the
rail network is so important now in West
Yorkshire we are whilst governments say
96 billion has been spent on on
um upgrades 50 billion of that is not is
coming to Birmingham so you know what is
actually being spent in the north is not
good enough and that's why I'm making
the case that we need that new line from
Manchester to Leeds with that really
important through stop in Bradford we
need fast trains from Sheffield to Leeds
we still haven't had a year after the
IRP I mean a year and two months now we
were promised
a plan from government how we're going
to get fast trains from Sheffield to
Leeds we haven't even had the terms of
reference we need a t-shaped station in
Leeds there is so much we need that will
get people out of their cars and onto
the trains but we need government to
backers so it's it's really important
now I don't have responsibilities for
health in the same way that Andy does
but I know that
um better mental well-being lower stress
opportunities for better health will
come from access to jobs ability to have
training so you can get a better paid
job we know that there's a this is a
public health approach isn't it it's not
just health over here transport skills
housing over here it is completely
integrated and that's where a strategic
plan from Mayors really does help to
have that Vision but I think the we
could go further in leveling up talking
about the climate emergency and we're
happy to work with government to do that
my green jobs task force I pledged a
thousand green jobs for young people
we've already hit that Target halfway
through the term I know there's an
appetite for it and we're ready to
deliver for government
I'm Stacy Andy
well I I think what you said in your
question is absolutely righty and more
public control of the system uh
transport or you could broaden this to
energy or housing
the more public control you have the
more you can dictate the pace of
decarbonization
and you just can't do that in a
deregulated transport system so as we
move towards the B Network
the first re-regulated services will
start in Wigan and Bolton and parts of
Salford next September on that day 17th
of September which will be the the day
that
re-regulated Services return to parts of
England outside of London we will
introduce 50 electric buses into service
in that area in those in those
franchises and they are currently being
built in the north of England at
Alexander Dennis that's a great leveling
up story isn't it that we're we are
building electric buses in the north of
England that will enter service in the
north of England uh next year and
there's a pipeline beyond that uh and
you know we we've got a a plan actually
for a a zero carbon public transport
system within a decade and that will be
the UK's first are trams already run on
renewable energy and that's a success
story I think of the city region if you
then add into that uh if you like
quadrupling the size of that trans
system by supplementing it by uh
hundreds of electric buses as as we will
in time I think as Tracy said before you
you will have a public transport system
by the end of the decade that's cheaper
to run and brings huge amount of health
benefits to our to our residents
um and we'll be superior there'll be no
needs for for people to travel in cars
to the extent that they do today so it
is about the public control in the
system and I think if you apply the
principle more broadly you would speed
up the decarbonization of the energy
grid and you would speed up the
retrofitting of housing if more of it
was under under public control or or at
least if there was Stronger regulation
of those sectors thanks Andy thanks yeah
right thanks uh we all want to see
um leveling up become a success to
pursue that tissue mayor Robinson Mary
thank you chair the National Audit
office has reported that there's been a
great deal of local government policy
churn since 1978.
and I I've got over 50 different
initiatives here which include city
challenge English Partnerships
neighborhood management Pathfinders Etc
and to what extent are these new new
initiatives uh is that helpful or
essential or is it period of stability
more likely to enable sustainable
long-term Investments Tracy well Mary I
completely agree with you but often
those
projects are at the because there's been
a funding opportunity and we've seen
haven't we the leveling up the precursor
of leveling up whether that's the
industrial strategy Northern Powerhouse
the pan for growth and now leveling up
certainty continuity is incredibly
important and I think the churn that
we've seen over the last few years in
the in the 20 months that I've been
mayor whether that's Prime Ministers or
plans or projects
um I think has been destabilizing and
not helpful I think when it comes to
we're talking about the prosperity fund
the three-year funding we need long-term
political
backing and strategic planning and
that's why I've been making the case to
government that mass transit which is a
real game changer for which Yorkshire
leads is the only city in Europe without
a mass transit system that has to go
beyond many different colors of
government
and will be a decade-long project so the
200 million that's been allocated saying
to government you've got to commit and
obviously to the labor party as well
that this has got to be something that
everybody gets behind because this will
be a real tool to level up our
communities with that integrated
transport system that Andy was talking
about where you have mass transit in
this in the city of Leeds that reaches
out to areas that have been disconnected
for centuries and that will be opened up
by that um that exciting transport plan
but we need certainty and stability and
we need a strategic plan that we can all
buy into
so you'd be saying to government no new
initiatives please let's just get on
with these well what I'd be saying is
give us that funding settlement
um a five to seven year funding
settlement that then we can
strategically plan with you to help you
deliver on your outcomes our local
outcomes and we can bring that stability
to our region
in terms of the UK's best interest do we
need to make sure that the leveling up
agenda works absolutely it is absolutely
critical for Regions that have really
suffered over the last couple of decades
it's absolutely critical for West
Yorkshire and of course the wider North
could I just say Mary I think that
question just asked is absolutely the
right question it's it's critical if
we're going to bring
the country through this period and and
bring it back together if you like the
whole notion now of regional inequality
is is out there is at the top of the
political agenda in many ways I've
waited all my political life for this
moment when we get more serious about
Regional inequality well well it's out
there and the positive is the cry for
fairer and more equal to treatment for
the north of England is not going to go
away it's it's only going to get louder
but let's work then on a cross-party
basis to put in place that what is
needed truly to to bring the north of
England closer to the living standards
of the south of England and the
transport standards and I think the way
that's done is not higher initiatives
I mean nothing wrong with the odd one
here or there but the way it's actually
done is if you rewire the way the
country works and you put in place long
term
funding that goes to the areas that need
it need it most and that is the German
model that I've referenced a couple of
times in this in this session I think
you have to make it a kind of national
Mission rather than just a sort of you
know the the
um source of a few press releases around
the leveling up fund I mean that is you
know that isn't leveling up what what
they did in eastern uh Germany after the
wall came down and when they went
towards reunification that was leveling
up that was a proper long-term funded
program to to deliver Equity across the
whole of the country and I think we've
hit a moment here where we need to do
the same because if we don't the sort of
the fractiousness in our politics I
think will only will only grow and the
kind of sense of uh of unfairness and
neglect will only will only um get get
deeper so yeah I think this is something
where there is cross-party agreement you
know we need more of that sometimes
don't we combined authorities are
working Devolution in England is working
it is making a difference as we've said
today but now is the time really to back
it we've kind of hit this end of the
beginning sort of moment Now's the Time
through this Trailblazer but also what's
coming uh Beyond we really need to back
it now and let this growth be created uh
across across all parts of England
thank you Andy I believe it's been
estimated that halving the productivity
gap between the North and the South will
add about 83 billion to the UK GDP is
that what this leveling upper gender is
about too
it's absolutely it is it's about the
whole country benefiting isn't it from a
from an area that's you know firing on
all cylinders I think you often we
describe the UK economy as I was firing
on properly on one cylinder well you
know just imagine if you know if if all
parts of the country were punching their
way and just to Echo Tracy the northern
Powerhouse concept was first put forward
a decade ago by George Osborne was
actually a very valid Concept in terms
of bringing the cities together
better connecting them and by doing that
helping them punch their weight and that
Railway line across the north of England
from Liverpool through Manchester
Airport Manchester Bradbury with Leeds
and Beyond critically important actually
and I and I still believe in the concept
of the northern Powerhouse uh and I
think we've got to kind of stop chopping
and changing and just get on with when
we say something as a country let's do
it for for once rather than constantly
changing our mind and uh and trying to
rewrite the script I think we know what
we want we all want the same thing
hopefully well let's just get on and do
it thank you just a final question
um Tracy one of the themes that this
inquiries so far has been the challenge
your surrounding deliverability uh
funding for leveling up what's the one
thing that needs to change or improve in
order to ensure
um the delivering uh the level of
leveling up agenda what's the one thing
that you would say and I'm guessing that
a block grant and a single single pot
would be undies Anza Mary you've you've
you've guessed right
um I think to end those
um the funding pots the bidding to have
that block funding that holders to
account to deliver on outcomes and uh
we'll be there and I think that would be
a real game changer uh at the speed at
which we can deliver leveling up as well
thank you thank you Tracy and thank you
Andy okay thank you Mary
um thank you both and thank you to uh
Andy Street who had to leave us a few
minutes ago for coming and giving us
what I think was a
um an excellent
um review of what's Happening uh with
Devolution and what more could be
achieved uh if that Devolution went
further and leveling up was really
delivered so thanks I think you've
thrown out a lot of challenges both to
this committee and to government and
indeed to the labor opposition as well
about where we go to in the future so
thank you all very much for coming
that's been a really interesting and
informative session for us thank you
thanks for the opportunity thank you
it's been a pleasure thanks everyone
thank you thank you it's good to be back